when you picture a grizzled police
officer few TV cops fit the bill as well
as Jason Bay's Chicago PD character
Squad Commander Hank voy but that
grizzled voice isn't an acting Choice
it's a reminder of a near-death
experience Hank void is a classic
example of the well-worn cynical Loose
Cannon archetype and beay knows how to
look and act tough but best of all he
has that unforgettably rough sounding
voice to convincingly sell his crime
fighting Persona on screen only a
chainsm smoking gargoyle who drinks
broken glass for breakfast could hope to
match the gravitas and be's voice we
don't have enough to get a search War
for his damn house be's role as Hank
Voit began in season 1 of Chicago Fire
since then the character has become
iconic making guest appearances in
several other network television
procedurals including in Law and Order
Special Victims Unit Chicago Med and
Chicago justice as well as Chicago PD
when fans first meet his character in
Chicago Fire voyd seems to be a dirty
cop who covers up criminal activities
for self-interest but as Chicago PD and
future appearances confirm there is much
more more bubbling beneath the surface
of this complicated law enforcement
leader and you're telling me you won't
give me a warrant based on a tip from a
reliable informant and as fans know the
Gay's voice is Pitch Perfect for vo's
character however it's not a voice that
he's had to tweak over time to perfect
that's his real life voice what Chicago
PD fans might not know is that his voice
wasn't always so pleasantly rough on the
ears his distinctively gritty sound is
the result of a car accident that the
star had in 1999 and that near-death
experience forever altered the actor's
life in an interview with The Daily
Beast pay explained that his naturally
deep voice became exacerbated as a
result of the terrible car accident he
said I broke my neck my back in a couple
of places all of my ribs both of my
lungs I was in a coma for 3 and 1/2
weeks when I would come out of the coma
since I was intubated from being on life
support I would pull the tube out and it
made it even more up the change in tone
is clear when you look at some of his
pre-accident roles like his guest turn
on melo's place kind of FL T in the face
of that all manner created equal thing I
dedicated my life to defend the fact
that this brush with death would help a
gay play his most famous role years down
the line is a silver lining to an
otherwise dire situation however his
deep voice comes in handy for more than
just playing bad cop within the same
interview Bay joked that his voice also
helps him play tough Dad when I say hey
it's time to clean up they do it beyond
the accident giving him the perfect
voice for a morally gray cop pay
acknowledges how the accident had a
serious effect on his life and interview
with the Pittsburgh Post Gazette in 2021
the gay discussed how the car accident
affected him psychologically technically
I did die for a short period of time
when I was in the coma that was
definitely an experience that profoundly
informed my perception of what life is
20 years later it's not something I
think about very often but as you bring
it up to me I do believe that I've
probably permanently changed since then
perhaps that is why beay appreciates
void's direct demeanor which pushes his
fellow Chicago PD characters to live
authentically and stand by their point
of view in 2023 pay reflected on voit's
non-nonsense character stating one thing
that Voit insists on and admires and
it's hard for team to do is he always
wants you to be you don't be me he
doesn't want a team of voids it can
create some tension but it does create
trust the right thing to the right thing
are you kidding me you want to talk
about the right
[Music]
thing